well joining us now is Labour's shadow
defense secretary at near Griffiths
thank you very much for being with us
today we've just been watching that film
from Grimsby and an area that clearly
voted heavily to leave the EU are you
worried when you listen to people saying
they voted labour before the parents of
voted labour but now because of brexit
because of your position on the second
referendum they may vote for the
Conservatives I think the point is that
people up and down the country are sick
and tired of talking about brexit and
the failure of this Tory government
after three years to get any sort of
deal which would be in any way
acceptable to people and the point is
that Labour's policy is very clear that
we will be giving people that
opportunity to vote on a final deal we
will be renegotiating that final deal
and we will be giving them the
opportunity to choose between that and
remain and I think the people in Grimsby
are also well aware of the huge
transformational programme that Labour
is offering firstly to rebalance the
economy to invest in areas like Grimsby
and of course our green industrial
revolution is going to bring a lot of
jobs to Grimsby so they know they've got
a very good MP and man Leon who's also
pointed out that there are many other
issues that people in greens we are
worried about they've seen the austerity
from the Tories they've seen their
services cut to the bone and they know
that with a Labour government they could
get the investment they need in jobs
plus the investment they need in their
services I don't doubt there are people
in Grimsby to whom that message on
austerity on on investment really
appeals but I have to be honest speaking
to those people in the market I'm not
sure that the message on Brett so even
if it's clear it's what they want to
hear is it well the point is Parliament
has completely failed under this Tory
government to resolve well the issue of
breaks it so that is why we are saying
that it is absolutely right that the
people should decide and so the people
of rooms you will have that opportunity
under a Labour government okay I just
wanna have a look at some polling and
that we have got exclusively for the
show today it's from you go and also the
Centre for towns and doing some really
interesting stuff on how people vote in
towns and this is ex industrial towns so
the kind of labour hot lines have you
like at the 2017 general election
according to this research fifty percent
said that they vote Labour
37% conservative in
area and the current voting intention
though that's now changed just 27
percent say they vote labor and 32
percent conservatives I'll just show you
another graph as well again this is from
the same research from the Center for
towns and new gov this shows that the
Conservatives are leading in every
single area apart from core cities
villages communities small towns medium
towns large towns and I should say that
the core city lead for labor has also
dropped significantly as well from 23
points in 2017 to just five points
currently only you worried when you look
at these figures this would point
towards a conservative victory wouldn't
it well I think what you have to
remember is what what happened in 2017
was that from a very low base labor made
enormous progress during that election
so this is a snapshot now but when our
manifesto is published next week when
people have a real chance to look at the
transformative change we're proposing
the real change that we're proposing in
their lives
then I think we will see a change in
these polls but do you not worry though
that there's a problem here with your
message not getting through particularly
in some of the areas where you've really
relied on people for support for many
times Grimsby for example returning a
Labour MP in every election since 1945
and yet many people they're clearly
concerned about the directional party
and a particular boxer well we will
never ever be complacent about any part
of the country but the fact of the
matter is that people are absolutely fed
up of austerity they are fed up of the
polarization investment only to certain
parts of the country and we are going to
make absolutely certain that every part
of the country benefits from the
investment we're going to make
particularly taking on the issue of the
green industrial revolution jobs that
will help to respond to the climate
change crisis and to make sure that
people have proper services so there's a
lot for you to look at in the next
couple of weeks and I think we will see
these polls change and before your
interview we spent a long time talking
to you Kasich wanting the Energy
Minister compliment and he was talking
about this dossier that the
Conservatives had produced which claims
that a Labour government would cost the
country an additional 1.2 trillion
pounds over five years what's your
reaction to this well quite clearly that
it conservative put this up because they
want this headline to try and rubbish
labour but as you quite rightly pointed
out you've just been speaking to quasi
cotton and he just couldn't explain
the figures these figures are absolutely
ludicrous they've come from absolutely
nowhere
they've been cobbled together by the
Tories and the important point here is
that when we publish our manifesto next
week we shall also be publishing all the
cost things that go with that and the
reason the Tories are trying to rubbish
this is because they know we're going to
have a much more exciting manifesto than
what they've produced and don't forget
in 2017 we also cost it every promise
that we made whereas the toys didn't
cost a single thing although Boyce
Johnson told me personally that they
would be a fully costed manifesto from
the Conservative Party in their defense
they say that all these figures are
labor policy announcements or things
that have been passed at your conference
and things that your Shadow Cabinet have
committed to well I can actually take
the use of face value me well I think
the I think as I've just said they can't
really explain the figures some of them
are I rolled together figures we're not
going to be implementing every single
thing that was in our our conference and
in this semester Labour Party democracy
is supposed to work they but you can
only do a certain amount at once can't
you so when you when we have the
manifesto published we will I can assure
you of the full cost things for what
we're going to be able to do in the next
five years and every single announcement
that we have made John McDonnell has
been absolutely strict with us on the
discipline of being able to explain
exactly where the money's going to come
from for each one okay now it's
remembrance and Remembrance Sunday today
and a day where many of us being
inflecting on the sacrifices made by
generations that come before us and you
are announcing more help for veterans
what is it that you want to do well
absolutely I mean today is Remembrance
Sunday it's absolutely right and proper
that we remember the contribution that
veterans made both in their military
life but also in their civilian lives
afterwards and what we are saying is
that as you very well know most
Stratton's transition very very well
into civilian life
but we want to enhance their
opportunities so labour is saying the
real change that we will bring is a
right to lifelong learning and training
so that the skills that ex-military
personnel have learnt in the forces can
be brought into civilian life can have
qualifications that are properly
recognized and that employers can
recognize those skills of course we're
also very very
the complete failure of the Tory
government to deal with mental health
issues and we are going to make the
investment so that every single veteran
wherever they live in the country can
get proper access promptly to both the
met first physical and mental health
services that they need and I'm sure
that many of your viewers would have
been quite horrified to see people lying
sleeping rough sleeping in the streets
of our big cities particulars it's
getting colder towards the winter and we
are very clear that we will be making
sure that those veterans are housed
promptly and given the support that they
need and it feels as if we have become
somewhat worried about the idea of
military intervention in recent years
perhaps the legacy of Iraq I'm thinking
will say about and the Syrian conflict
can you see any scenarios where a Labour
government would commit to overseas
military intervention well look there's
certainly we've all learned from the
Chilcott report very important lessons
about what
intervention is about and how you need
to think carefully what is the aftermath
and what are the be the consequences so
of course we're going to be thinking
very carefully about any military
intervention but know we are part of a
NATO alliance will also take very
seriously our role in the and we think
it's very important that the UK should
have a very strong voice on the world
stage and I think you only need to look
at the terrible terrible and sorted that
there was in in in the Balkans before we
intervened there and Syria where we
didn't Andy and the issue of Rwanda
again where people felt that we had let
things go on for far too long there so
there are going to be cases where we are
not going to be able to walk by on the
other side because we take very
seriously
the the well-being and the human rights
of people across the world and also of
course we have to deal with the threats
that there are to our country here and
so very often what we do abroad is
actually very directly affecting our
security here I'm interested in Trident
as well and in blackwood was talking
earlier
about the SNP opposition to the renewal
of Trident we know that John McDonnell
and Jeremy Corbyn at both said they
wouldn't use it John McDonnell in 2018
Jeremy Corbyn in 2015 admittedly some
years ago would a Labour government be
prepared to use the nuclear weapons the
nuclear deterrent well we are absolutely
committed to keeping our nuclear terms
it's not quite what I asked though no
difference between keeping it I'm coming
down and we are absolutely committed to
keeping the nuclear deterrent with it's
a very very important part of our
defence particularly now as we see a
resurgent Russia and we see the you know
the u.s. perhaps being a little bit
lukewarm about NATO it's very important
the UK takes a leading role there and
Jeremy fully understands what deterrence
means now no Prime Minister ever reveals
exactly what they write when they write
the the letter and so it wouldn't be
appropriate for me to make any comment
but I can assure you that the defense of
this country is absolutely foremost in
Jeremy's mind it is a fair question to
ask whether or not a Labour government
would be prepared to use a deterrent
that we spend so much money on renewing
well I think the the whole point about
deterrence is that you don't give away
well the whole point is that you have to
be prepared to use that doesn't it that
the whole point is that you don't give
away the exact circumstances or what you
would actually do it's that element of
doubt about deterrence which is very
very important as part of that
deterrence and as I have said no Prime
Minister has ever revealed exactly what
they have written down and the situation
of course would be exactly the same for
us I'm not asking to reveal exactly what
Jeremy Corbyn prime minister would write
down in the instructions that as you say
a private eye locked away burned after
that Prime Minister sets down what I'm
asking is in principle if a Labour
government would be prepared to use a
nuclear deterrent well the point is the
whole issue about having a deterrent is
that there is that element of doubt in
your opponent's minds and so therefore
it serves its purpose as a deterrent if
I ask the defence secretary he would
give me a clear answer on this but as I
said the point is that we have the term
because we absolutely believe that we
should
have that deterrent and that's our
Labour Party policy and as I've said
that is part of the theory of deterrence
okay and now I just want to talk to you
quickly about anti-semitism we're
talking to quasi quatl about
Islamophobia in the conservative party
and now so far we've seen around 6
labour candidates who either quit or
been forced to stand down because of
allegations around and Semitism whether
it's Commons that they've made in the
past just to give a couple of examples
Gideon bull candidate in Clapton for
calling a Jewish countless [ __ ] cake
rounds in Canada in Aberdeen show
comparing Israel to an abusive adult I
mean it's just the first week of the
campaign what's going on why can't you
shake these kind of allegations
well we absolutely must have the highest
standards in public life and we must
absolutely stamp out all forms of
anti-semitism and other forms of racial
prejudice and LGBT prejudice and so
where we do unfortunately discover such
things it's absolutely right and proper
that we have a proper investigation and
the Pro Protection is taken and that's
why we are taking the action that we are
taking their problem is it feels like
these stories are starting to cut
through I mean we were hearing from
Grimsby some of the people in Grimsby
earlier and just still remember one girl
who was I was talking to Jeremy Corbyn
fan labour supporter she likes what
you're doing on austerity she doesn't
like Boris Johnson she really wants to
vote for you and yet she still said this
to me when I spoke to her in a Grimsby I
covered market about Jeremy Corbyn he's
been accused of saying things that are
racist and you know anti-semitic somatic
and stuff but I think some of the things
he's doing a really good he's trying to
support young people more I mean this is
someone who is on your side and yet the
messages about anti-semitism are still
filtering through this must be deeply
frustrating well as you know Jeremy
absolutely is not anti-semitic and he is
not racist and he would immediately
condemn those sorts of comments that
you've quoted earlier but the point is
we do need to make sure that we we stamp
this out in the party we do need to make
sure that candidates are properly
investigated so why hasn't happened them
well that the point is that we are we
are making sure that we do investigate
where things come to light we are making
sure that we
do investigate and that we do take
action